[Music]
welcome back to cbs mornings this
women's history month our new series
changing the game is profiling
extraordinary women making an impact now
and for future generations this morning
we meet a leader in the fight for
domestic labor and care workers rights
you know more than 90 percent of those
roles are filled by women and more than
half of them by women of color i genpoos
work has drawn the attention of
billionaire philanthropist melinda
french gates whose company was behind
part of a 10 million dollar grant for
pu's group jamie yukis sat down with
both women at the los angeles non-profit
e-bell which has a mission to educate
and uplift women
everybody feels invisible and isolated
and struggling
because we haven't supported them and
that's the opportunity here for more
than two decades igenpoo has been
drawing attention to a so-called
invisible workforce as the executive
director of the national domestic
workers alliance she advocates for the
country's caregivers we represent the
two and a half million women who work
inside of our homes who make everything
else possible who says proper
recognition and compensation for the
home care aides nannies and house
cleaners are long overdue
what a child care worker an early
childhood educator produces
is human potential
what a home care worker produces
is dignity and quality of life for the
people who raised us
what could be more valuable
why is igen a game changer
oh my gosh igen is a game changer
because she has been advocating in this
caregiving space for so long and she's
really elevated it on the national stage
melinda french gates first met igenpoo
through the bill and melinda gates
foundation as a privileged businesswoman
philanthropist and mother she
immediately recognized the critical
nature of pooh's work we would be
talking to single moms in low income
settings and hearing their struggle you
know saying my gosh i used to rely on my
mom to take care of my children so i a
single mom can work now i'm taking care
of my mother and i don't know where to
put my children it hit the nail on the
head i thought oh my god this is
impossible for these women the pandemic
really put us all in a different kind of
crisis like our kids were home from
school struggling with online learning
our parents on lockdown in nursing homes
or thousands of miles away and we can be
doing everything right
and without the programs and policies
that support caregiving it's just not
enough why are we so far behind
well i think because so often in the
united states we think of the workforce
as kind of what it was like in the 1950s
where you know one person went off with
their briefcase to the office and the
woman stayed home
and yet today of all the kids in the u.s
25 have a single parent and of all
families 54 are dual income earners i
see you really nodding your head yeah i
mean i think we have this assumption
that care is kind of a personal
responsibility that
is to be managed mostly by the women in
our households right and if we can't
figure it out we consider it a personal
failure we actually need
policies systems programs a workforce
and i think it really starts with
investing in care programs child care
paid leave
home and community-based care for the
aging and our care workforce that has
been so undervalued i mean the average
annual income of a home care worker in
this country is eighteen thousand two
hundred dollars per year how is that
sustainable i mean imagine trying to
take care of your kids
so the people we count on to care for us
as their profession can't care for
themselves and their own families doing
this work these are also jobs in our
economy right some of the fastest
growing occupations in our entire
economy are child care workers and home
care workers there is a proposal called
the better care better jobs act that
would invest in the home care workforce
it would be the biggest investment in
the creation of good jobs for women and
women of color in the history of this
country
and it would be profound because this is
a group of workers that has never fully
been recognized as the professionals and
skilled workers that they are you'll be
a game changer well that's is there a
lesson here too that when women support
other women stuff gets done yes yes yes
[Laughter]
that was jamie yukis reporting